Google helped ran down the hole hold on
not too fast oh oh I would have given
you whatever you needed and if Theon
found out he'd hang them the boy can't
survive on walnuts I'm fine
you've been walking since before sunrise
even holdall tire Oh
even you sweet giant oh hold on it's all
right
you've got a big mouth girl and too many
teeth stop it you've been fighting
what's he going on about
and how come he always gets to sit and
chat while we do all the work
hold on bill nan said they turn your
skull into a cup mate drink your own
blood for me that's all nan said a storm
coming and I've heard all about Hodor
Hodor oh yeah
holy good this knife cut me loose get it
nice Willis I saw you as a boy you could
talk what happened hold on
where's Mira
mudal I thought that hotel wasn't always
hodor hodor his real name is Willis we
can go home now hold up well maybe not
home home but somewhere that isn't a
cave okay he's something that isn't moss
I would an egg how'd you like a boils
with a rasher of bacon and some blood
sausage